that cosmopolitan will have a new
operator thanks for joining us here at
noon i'm heather mills this morning mgm
resorts announced it reached a deal with
blackstone real estate for more than a
billion dollars hector mejia joining us
live on the strip with details about the
sale and what it means for you hector
well mgm resort said in a press release
this is part of its vision to be a world
leader in the gaming and entertainment
industries and for guests who come to
the cosmopolitan
this will mean they'll have another
resort where they can earn their mgm
loyalty program points
under the deal mgm resorts will take
over the operations of the cosmopolitan
from blackstone real estate for 1.6
billion dollars cash we've learned it's
a 30-year long-term lease with three
10-year renewal options available unlv
gaming historian david short says it
will mean one fewer option of having an
independent operator on the las vegas
strip there's a lot of good tax reasons
to split it with between the property
owners and the operators it's also a way
for mgm to focus on what they call their
asset light strategy
where they are more interested in
operating things than owning things mgm
will pay an initial annual rent of 200
million dollars the company already has
13 properties on the strip including the
iconic bellagio aria mandalay bay and
the mirage it does give mgm a really big
chunk of the strip you know basically
from bellagio on down to mandalay bay
so they definitely own that part of the
strip now the 3 000 room luxury resort
and casino opened back in 2010
blackstone bought it in 2014 and spent
over 500 million dollars in upgrades
including renovating rooms
and this transaction is expected to
close in the first half of 2020 2022
rather in the first half of 2022 pending
regulatory approval reporting live from
the las vegas strip hector mejia live
local now